e.t can confirm roy horn of the
legendary siegfried and roy
has died from complications from
coronavirus
he was 75. siegfried released a
statement about his long
time collaborator's passing saying in
part
today the world has lost one of the
greats of magic
but i have lost my best friend from the
moment we met i knew roy and i together
would change the world there could be no
siegfried without roy
and no roy without siegfried roy had a
connection
always has a connection with the animals
which i
still don't understand today you know
it is what it is there is a bondage with
what he has and
that's his life that's his lifestyle and
maybe he was a tiger before his life
siegfried and roy performed their
infamous las vegas show from 1990 until
it abruptly came to a close
in 2003. well there are always
incidents happening but if something
happened like that is always us
because we human beings are very easily
try to make animals domestic and
we just going too far sometimes so it's
our fault no matter what happens
during their final show at the mirage
roy sustained
life-threatening injuries after being
attacked by a white tiger named
manticore roy would later insist
manticore was attempting to save him
after he suffered a stroke
he saved my life you clarified he saved
your life you're saying that you had
this stroke before and fell down
and then that's when he came to pick you
up like a mother with a cub
well we really don't say hit the stroke
before
but he passed out he passed out on the
stage you passed out before the incident
well yeah i know i had a heart attack
but i
i also then i hit the operation and
to release the press i was painting but
she took the whole top of the head off
and doing that i meant three more
strokes i die clinically
three times on the operation table
following the incident siegfried and roy
the show
came to an end but siegfried and roy the
duo persevered
the collaborators dedicated themselves
to animal conservation
and frequently made appearances together
when the accident happened i thought
everything is stopped now it's no but
now i think we are in a good space
like i said we are not worried anymore
what we don't have we just enjoy
what we have and we are blessed
and he's blessed is a present
i'm thankful to god for every progress i
can take
i'll give you there and now they might
not only
look to the star i can't believe that
i'm there and still telling you stories
so tomorrow is there or look bright
just like the white line of our tiger
when they've been seen in the back
the people leave their reincarnation of
their gods and have the answers
so and signified new hope according to
the statement on roy's passing
there will be a public memorial for roy
in the future